zdf heute live herzlich willkommen liebe
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer
es ist tag sechs der hochwasser
hochwasserkatastrophe im süden und
westen deutschlands und noch immer
bergen feuerwehren tote männer frauen
und kinder alleine im kreis ahrweiler in
rheinland pfalz werden noch 155 menschen
vermisst und wir sprechen darüber wie
die hilfe vor ort voran kommt und wie es
den helfern und opfern geht und wir
blicken direkt dort ins zentrum hinein
nach bad neuenahr ahrweiler dass wir
hier im norden von rheinland pfalz
gesehen haben zu meinem kollegen bobby
gene bobby du bist schon seit einigen
tagen dort wie ist die lage im moment ja
im grunde geht die arbeit hier immer
weiter die bilder ähneln sich wann immer
man hier in die orte reinschaut
man sieht menschen mit schubkarren die
hier schlamm aus den häusern bringen die
möbel die nicht mehr zu retten sind an
die seite stellen
es gibt ganz viel hilfe auch von außen
hier sind nicht nur die einwohnerinnen
und einwohner der stadt bad neuenahr
ahrweiler die hier arbeiten sondern es
gibt auch ganz viel hilfe von draußen
es gibt menschen die schweres gerät
haben kipplaster von schrotthändlern zum
beispiel oder garten- und
landschaftsbaubetriebe die kommen hier
hin sammeln den müll auf in eigenregie
ein und bringen den dann zur deponie man
sieht auch ganz viele menschen die hier
stände aufgebaut haben
verpflegungsstände das sind privatleute
private firmen die dafür sorgen dass auf
der einen seite die anwohnerinnen und
anwohner etwas zu essen zu trinken haben
aber eben auch die vielen helferinnen
und helfer aber bei diesem ausmaß der
zerstörung die das wasser hier
hinterlassen hat ist auch klar
die arbeit wird noch sehr sehr lange
weiter gehen also von einem
normalzustand ist man sehr weit entfernt
es geht nur sehr langsam vorwärts aber
es geht vorwärts
wir gucken uns das gleich im detail an
und sehen auch dass es so schwierig ist
weil es mehrere zehntausende menschen
sind die betroffenen sind rund um bad
neuenahr ahrweiler aber auch im
südlichen nordrhein-westfalen und in
im nördlichen rheinland-pfalz marion
geiger fast das alles noch mal zusammen
innerhalb von fünf minuten stand das
wasser kniehoch in der praxis von
zahnarzt werner jung in altena er selbst
kam knapp raus aus der wilden flut in
seiner praxis aber ist alles kaputt
der 67 jährige wollte eigentlich noch
weitermachen
doch nun steht die praxis vor dem aus
das ganze machen
ich habe mich da also mittlerweile mit
abgefunden ist natürlich scheiße ab und
zu kriegt man natürlich immer so in
beiden krampf nachts
ich muss ja nix in all den trümmern
gestaltet sich die medizinische
versorgung der flutopfer schwierig
rettungskräfte bringen medikamente und
zwei mobile arztpraxen sind im landkreis
ahrweiler unterwegs große sorge bereiten
der einsatzleitung die hygienischen
verhältnisse denn schlamm und
flusswasser sind verseucht durch heizöl
abwasser müll und tierkadaver wir sind
im moment dabei verstärkt
tierkörperbeseitigung voranzutreiben so
dass das sozusagen rausgenommen wird die
bevölkerung muss sich an unsere vorgaben
halten es ist tatsächlich im moment
gefährlich
das wasser der aa zu nutzen
zudem wird befürchtet dass corona virus
könnte sich im chaos der katastrophe
unkontrolliert ausbreiten
in bad neuenahr ahrweiler ist seit
mittag ein impf busse im einsatz
impfen und testen gibt es hier ohne
anmeldung der andrang groß um eine
zweite impfung wäre jetzt am freitag
gewesen und dies halt ausgefallen weil
die praxis selber abgesoffen ist ja und
jetzt habe ich die chance genutzt um
eine zweite impfung auf jeden fall zu
bekommen
es wird lange dauern die zerstörte
infrastruktur im a teil wieder
aufzubauen
die menschen hier werden viel
unterstützung brauchen und eine davon
ist jetzt bei meinem kollegen bobby gene
in bad neuenahr-ahrweiler bobby was
berichten die die menschen vor ort und
was könnt ihr jetzt in diesem moment
berichten ja bei mir ist jetzt daria
breuer sie wohnt hier in bad
neuenahr-ahrweiler zusammen mit ihrem
sohn und hat die flutkatastrophe des die
hochwasserkatastrophe hier lebt probier
das ist vergangene woche passiert in der
nacht von mittwoch auf donnerstag
was haben sie da erlebt zu hause bei
sich das wasser aus allen kellerräumen
gleichzeitig ein wo ich noch ein paar
sachen retten wollte und bin einfach nur
noch nach oben gegangen büro unterlagen
zu sichern versicherungsunterlagen und
dann war das im erdgeschoss wirklich
schon hier bauch hoch und dann habe ich
einfach umgedreht und habe zugesehen hat
sich ins obergeschoss kommen
das heißt für sie war das tatsächlich
eine lebensbedrohliche situation weil es
hätte auch anders ausgehen kann man sich
zu denken wenn ich nicht mehr umgedreht
hätte und wer ins büro rein gegangen ich
weiß ich nicht was passiert wäre keine
ahnung wie steht es jetzt um ihr zuhause
das wasser war halt wirklich körper hoch
da und es liegt alles in trümmern oder
es lag alles in trümmern weil dank ganz
vielen netten menschen und helfern die
bei mir durch die tür kommen ist es
mittlerweile einigermaßen entrümpelt und
der schlamm ist jetzt auch langsam raus
also heute so die letzten reste aber
zumindest sieht man wieder fließen
und parkettboden sie haben gerade die
helferinnen und helfer angesprochen
wie erleben sie hier die hilfe vor ort
und wie funktioniert das läuft das
reibungslos oder sehen sie irgendwo noch
verbesserungspotenzial
jede menge verbesserungspotenzial weil
es wird halt zentral so ist der eindruck
von uns betroffenen der vielleicht irrt
aber irgendwie ist der eindruck so dass
es überhaupt nicht koordiniert ist die
hilfe die da ist die enorme hilfe die
wirklich da ist von privatmenschen
menschen fremde menschen die hier
hinkommen die einfach nur helfen wollen
die geräte dabei haben private
bauunternehmer private garten und
landschaft leute einfach ganz viele
unternehmen und landwirte vor allen
dingen die ihre geräte einsetzen und
mitbringen aber die sich alle selbst
organisieren und teilweise von der
kreisverwaltung wohl weggeschickt werden
wie wir als betroffene hören war wenn
die nicht da gewesen wären dann würde
das hier noch aussehen wie donnergrollen
was leiten sie daraus ab was wünschen
sie sich was muss sich denn ändern ja
eigentlich eine leitung eine
leitungsstelle einfach einen
katastrophenschutz stelle die das hier
alles koordiniert die die leute
irgendwie einsetzt an die richtigen
stellen das halt zuerst von draußen
entrümpelt wird also von außen nach
innen da wieder raus die privaten helfer
die brauchen drei stunden teilweise um
auf dieser seite der anderen seite
brauchen wir glaube ich etwas anders aus
so wie wir hören aber alle brücken weg
sind ist auf der seite hier vom
kalvarienberg in ahrweiler hat eine
katastrophe jeder helfer der durchkommt
kommt entweder zu fuß oder braucht drei
stunden mit dem auto ich habe das
eingang zu sagt sie leben hier in bad
neuenahr-ahrweiler zusammen mit ihrem
sohn
wie macht man das jetzt grade wie machen
sie das gerade zusammen mit einem kind
sich darum zu kümmern das haus wieder
halbwegs herzurichten auch wenn sie
hilfe haben das ist ja sicher auch eine
betreuungs frage das ist ihr sohn mit
dabei der sohn ist nicht dabei ich
möchte auch nicht dass das anders sieht
weil das schon so geweint hat nach den
ersten warnungen weil er angst um sein
freund theo hatte und mein vater hat ihn
abgeholt also der großvater in also
abends an dem mittwoch abend und ich
wusste hat einen ganzen tag weil das
kommunikationsnetz zusammengebrochen war
nicht wie es den großeltern geht nicht
wie es dem sohn geht einen ganzen tag
lang licht
hab heut gebangt ob er überhaupt noch da
ist und jetzt ist die situation einfach
so dass wir überhaupt gar nicht wissen
wie wir hier alle eltern hier sind ganz
viele einfamilienhäuser mit ganz vielen
kinder an die nachbarn gegenüber
drei kleine kinder die wissen überhaupt
nicht wo sie ihre kinder lassen sollen
weil die halt nicht hier vor ort sein
sollen und jede familie organisiert
organisiert sich selbst und betreut
privat über großeltern freunde die
irgendwo in bonn wohnen in rahm asbach
oben wohnen also wir wünschen uns
einfach eine zentrale betreuung die
irgendwie zentral organisiert wird damit
wir als eltern unsere kinder häufiger
sehen
aktuell sehen wir sie manchmal tage
nicht weil wir einfach nicht wollen dass
die hierhin kommen und wir brauchen halt
drei stunden um die kinder zu sehen die
halt überall in der ganzen stadt oder
außerhalb der stadt verteilt sind und
betreut werden ja also die
kinderbetreuung ist offensichtlich auch
noch so ein punkt der hier noch nicht
geklärt ist natürlich die eltern müssen
versuchen hier die häuser in irgendeiner
form wieder herzurichten
alleine das dauert kinderbetreuung
aufräumen ist bleiben weiterhin sehr
sehr viele baustellen hier in bad
neuenahr-ahrweiler vielen dank boxx
serien für diese informationen und
vielen dank an seine gesprächspartnerin
für die vielen eindrücke die sie uns
gegeben hat und das möchte ich gerne
alles direkt aufgreifen und weitergeben
hier im studio ist nämlich jemand mit
dem wir darüber sehr gut sprechen können
und zwei jahren braun schädel vom
deutschen roten kreuz vom
drk-landesverband mainz also vom drk
landesverband rheinland pfalz mit sitz
hier in mainz braun schädel
sie waren in der region und haben eigene
eindrücke darüber würde ich gerne auch
noch sprechen aber zuerst würde ich
gerne auf das eingehen was die frau die
betroffene gerade gesagt hat und dass
ein bisschen aufdröseln fangen wir mal
hinten an
fehlende kinderbetreuung wir sind im
jahr 2021 in einem hoch entwickelten
land wie deutschland wir sehen diese
katastrophe die hat uns alle überrascht
aber wir sind am tag sechs offenbar
nicht in der lage als staat zu
organisieren dass diese menschen ihre
häuser wieder aufbauen können weil sie
nicht wissen wohin mit ihren kindern
können sie das erklären aus meiner
position heraus nicht ich bin ja selber
ein ehrenamtlicher helfer am ende ich
habe eine ausbildung als sanitäter wir
haben ein einsatz struktur die man
gelernt und der man ausgebildet wird
niemanden rein versetzt wird und der
mann in dem moment auch in einsatz
geschickt wird dann als ehrenamtlicher
der selber sonst beim normalen berufen
normalen alltag nachgeht da gibt es für
mich auch zwischen referat keine
unterschiede wir haben ein bisschen mehr
ausbildung wir können ein bisschen mehr
aber am ende sind wir auch ehrenamtliche
und es gibt eben keine ehrenamtliche
struktur für kinderbetreuung also es
gibt keine kindergärten voll musste die
man alarmieren kann und wohin schicken
kann
wir sind auch in ein land wo kinder
gärtner fädeln das wissen wir alle das
hat jetzt nichts mit der katastrophe zu
tun und strukturen müssen erstmal
geschaffen werden also auch wenn jetzt
kinderbetreuung notwendig ist ist eine
spontane struktur die entsteht sehr
schnell mit nachbarschaftshilfe über die
sozialen medien heutzutage aber das
professionell aufzubauen das dauert
einfach einen moment der bedarf ist
wahrscheinlich bekannt würde ich
vermuten
und das ist weiß dann müssen die
strukturen geschaffen werden das
betrifft auch uns selber im roten kreuz
wir sind jetzt permanent die lage
beobachten am eruieren wir haben einen
eigenen leitungsstab dafür der auch
sowas beobachtet das thema
kinderbetreuung war zum beispiel wir uns
heute schon ein thema wir haben im
jugendrotkreuz ein jugendverband der
sich dann gedanken macht wie können wir
da helfen konkret das sind selber kinder
und jugendliche mit natürlich
entsprechenden führungsstruktur mit
ausgebildeten leuten auch ehrenamtliche
die schon gesagt habe wir wollen uns was
überlegen vielleicht können wir eine
spontane kinderfreizeit organisieren
habe ich heute morgen auf dem flur
gehört so ein thema aber auch das muss
erst organisiert werden natürlich das
kriegt man vor ort nicht mit es gibt
viele organisationen des netz ist voll
davon die die situation auch ausnützen
dubiose verbände die versuchen genau da
anzusetzen kinderbetreuung anzubieten
obwohl sie unseriös sind und gerade im
kreis ahrweiler hat der landkreis auch
davon abgeraten bestimmten initiativen
dazu vertrauen die eben genau in diese
lücke diese lücke füllen wollen hier in
der community sehe ich sehr viel dank
und lob an die helfer eines möchte ich
gerne loswerden martina förster schreibt
über facebook ein lob den helfern und da
bin ich beim nächsten punkt den die dame
gerade angesprochen hat sie sagt es wird
gar nicht koordiniert was man sich ja
eigentlich auch gar nicht vorstellen
kann denn es sind ja nicht nur
freiwillige helfer also nicht nur
freiwillige ehrenamtler wie sie die
diesen job kennen sondern auch leute die
einfach aus dem bundesgebiet sagen ich
fahr dahin nicht helfen aber es sind ja
auch viele das thw ist da die
berufsfeuerwehren sind da die bundeswehr
ist da was
sie sagen über die koordination
verordnen wie kann es sein dass jemand
vor ort sagt hier ist überhaupt keine
koordination sowie das sieht man vor ort
sagen kann kann ich mir leicht erklären
jeder hat den blick erstmal auf den
punkt auf dem er ist also die dame steht
irgendwo in der stadt jetzt und sagt bei
mir ist keine hilfe
das heißt aber nicht dass keine hilfe da
ist wir haben ja hunderte einsatzorte
moment da oben also wir haben ja ein
ganzes zerstörtes tal und neben täler
die betroffen sind und auch nicht nur
die region wir haben ja noch in anderen
bundesländern einsatzstellen derzeit und
die ehrenamtlichen kräfte müssen alle
erstmal alarmiert in bewegung gesetzt
werden das ist sofort passiert die also
die ersten kräfte waren unmittelbar vor
ort die aus den nachbarlandkreisen die
von weiter weg mussten dann natürlich
erstmal zugeführt wenn die lage muss
dann erst mal klar sein das muss man
sich auch vorstellen wenn dann etwas
passiert muss erst mal irgendwo die
nachricht hin dringen an den
rettungsleitstellen okay da ist was dann
geht dieser alarmkette los jetzt sind
wir natürlich in der phase wo das alles
längst passiert ist es gibt einen
einsatzstab dort vor ort der die lage
führt auch der besteht übrigens aus sehr
vielen ehrenamtlichen diese stadt
engagieren natürlich auch sehr viel
hauptamtliches personal us behörden dass
da aktiv ist aber eine meldung die die
vor ort passiert wenn die damit sagt ich
brauche hier einen krankenwagen
dann muss das erst nach oben durch den
stab und wieder runter bzw
natürlich im notfall läuft für die
rettungsleitstelle dann ist es eine
gewohnte strukturen geht deutlich
schneller aber hilfe muss organisiert
werden und professionell organisiert
werden dass wir auch wissen wo unsere
kräfte sind man kann nicht blind leute
irgendwohin schicken dann weiß man gar
nicht mehr wo die sind und für viele
dieser einsatzlagen sind wir nicht
ausgebildeten haben wir auch nicht das
passende gerät in dem moment so was hat
man einfach hier noch nie erlebt ihr
sprechen gleich weiter schauen aber
auf eine zusammenfassung von peter böhme
der heute unter anderem auch begleitet
hat wie die bundeskanzlerin in
nordrhein-westfalen sich noch einmal ein
bild von der lage gemacht hat die
kanzlerin und der ministerpräsident von
nrw im krisengebiet mitten in
deutschland dieses mal in bad
münstereifel gespräche mit helfern und
betroffenen der politische versuch sich
ein bild zu machen von einer
apokalyptischen lage
es ist aber nicht unbedingt so dass die
leute hier auf die politprominenz
gewartet haben
das große große thema ist natürlich wie
geht's weiter und und wann kommen gelder
wie wie kann man weitermachen also
soforthilfemaßnahmen japan morgen will
das bundeskabinett genau darüber beraten
das land nrw will die dann für sich
bewilligten gelder verdoppeln und armin
laschet verspricht die formulare und die
anträge müssen ganz simpel sein ganz
einfach sein und sie sollen noch in
dieser woche fertig sein damit recht
bald das aus zahlen der ersten gelder
beginnen kann einfach simpel schnell
skepsis bei diesen geschäftsmann dessen
hutgeschäft einem rohbau gleicht nicht
überkochen
[Musik]
schon zwei jahre nichts verdient und
jetzt alles verloren die kanzlerin
spricht angesichts des trümmerfeldes von
entsetzlichen zuständen und verspricht
dauerhafte hilfe aber es ist auch sehr
klar dass wir hier einen sehr langen
atem brauchen werden und deshalb frau
bürgermeisterin unser landrat wir werden
sie nicht noch kurz zum vergessen
sondern wir werden uns immer wieder ein
bild darüber machen wie es mit dem
wiederaufbau steht und dieser
wiederaufbau wird wohl einige jahre
dauern
westfalen im krisengebiet war aber im
norden von rheinland-pfalz schildern sie
uns was sie da gesehen und erlebt haben
also in erster linie viel positives das
glaubt man zwar nicht weil es natürlich
eine schreckliche katastrophe ist aber
die auch die dame die eben david zu
sehen war die hilfe die man spürt und
wie angepackt wird untereinander wie die
bevölkerung sich auf die bevölkerung
auch helfern hilft das haben wir auch
erlebt ist sensationell
sieht man fotos auch minden gebracht
vielleicht können wir die zeigen während
sie erzählen da sieht man nämlich in
bildern wie diese hilfe aussieht also
also hier zum beispiel dass das sind
abgegebene hilfsgüter man sieht wie die
hilfsgüter auch natürlich unmittelbar
ausgegeben werden vieles muss sortiert
werden
es werden dann ausgabestellen gebildet
teilweise spontan haben wir gehört dass
der bevölkerung hier das ist unsere
eigene notunterkunft die wir betrieben
haben in der grafschaft ringen in der
nähe von bad neuenahr das entstanden die
dort vor ort direkt abgegeben wurden aus
der gemeinde die kollegen im gespräch
mit den betroffenen vor ort und
natürlich da sieht man auch sehr gut die
zusammenarbeit zwischen den
verschiedenen organisationen
das wird gibt dann einen
einsatzabschnitt und komplizierter
begriff bei uns eine turnhalle die wir
betreuen mit verschiedenen einheiten von
uns da war die polizei mit dabei der
menschen gewohnt da gibt es niemanden
der das ganze an führt das hat er
irgendwann mit der blauen weste gerade
also diese strukturen waren da und sind
auch von anfang an genutzt worden aber
man muss natürlich die dimensionen
erstmal erkennen und dann einsatzkräfte
auch dorthin führen das dauert alles
einen moment das ist längst passiert die
sind auch da und die sind auch im
einsatz die ganze zeit rund um die
nur noch nicht jeder kann 24 stunden um
einsatzzeiten und noch niemand hat diese
bilder direkt vor ort gesehen was hat
das mit ihnen gemacht das war
tatsächlich ein eindruck den man nicht
nicht anders beschreiben kann als
kriegsgebiet also das war mein erster
mein erster gedanke ich habe an der aa
gestanden am ehemaligen flussbett oder
dann wieder herstellten flussbett und
dann sieht diese trümmerteile daliegen
man sieht autos in bäumen hängen man
sieht menschen die von oben bis unten
mit schlamm bedeckt sind man sieht teile
von häusern
das ist für mich war das der
entscheidende unterschied in der
beobachtung hochwasser haben wir schon
mal gesehen einsatzkräfte kennen
hochwasser aber ein eingestürztes
wohnhaus also das sind die existenz
verliert und dass man ja auch weiß dass
auch in wohnhäuser noch menschen gewesen
werden können das trifft einen doch ins
mark ganz plötzlich dann damit sprechen
sie was an worüber wenig berichtet wird
und worüber auch ungern gesprochen wird
aber während wir hier reden sind
feuerwehren aus ganz deutschland im
einsatz um nach vermissten zu suchen und
kevin richard fragt über youtube ich
weiß die frage könnte naiv sein aber
werden noch überlebende vermisste
gefunden die frage ist nicht naiv
die wahrscheinlichkeit ist nach sechs
tagen sehr gering aber das findet in
diesen minuten statt dass feuerwehren
tote aus ihren häusern werden müssen die
auf der straße liegen die weggespült
wurden die in bäumen hängen
die seit sechs tagen dort verschüttet
wurden
darauf waren niemand hier vorbereitet
sie sind jetzt beim drk sie sind nicht
bei der feuerwehr das ist nicht teil
ihres jobs aber auch sie kennen dieses
vorgehen wie wie gehen die leute vor ort
damit um weil es ist schon teil unseres
jobs in zweierlei hinsicht auf der einen
seite sind auch unsere einsatzkräfte
damit konfrontiert weil in bereichen wo
man mit überlebenden rechnet schickt man
natürlich auch sanitäter hin um
überlebende zu versorgen
und manchmal stellt man eben fest dass
dann keiner mehr da ist und dann sind
unsere einsatzkräfte unmittelbar damit
konfrontiert und auf der anderen seite
ist eine sehr große aufgabe von uns die
psychosoziale nachsorge für betroffene
wie auch für einsatzkräfte wir haben
mittlerweile fast 200
fach ausgebildete kräfte dort oben alles
ehrenamtliche die eine fachausbildung
haben genau für diesen bereich die
einsatzkräfte betreuen genauso wie
betroffene betreuen die schwärmen
überall dort wo aus sie sind auch sehr
gut koordiniert wenn da bedarf bestehen
es gibt eine hotline für einsatzkräfte
es gibt auch eine hotline für betroffene
noch mal anrufen kann auch wenn man sich
nur mal ein paar minuten unterhalten
muss das kann sehr helfen
sehr wichtig sind auch einsatz
nachbesprechung meine eigene einheit in
der sich ehrenamtlich bin hier in mainz
macht jetzt im moment einen einsatz
nachbesprechung mit einem ausgebildeten
helfer in dem bereich der uns dann von
der feuerwehr quasi ausgeliehen wurde es
heute abend um einfach diese eindrücke
zu verarbeiten wie stellt man sich das
vor die sitzen in kreisen und erzählen
einfach was sie gesehen haben darüber
riefen ich würde ein moderiertes
gespräch
wie sich das dann genau entwickelt das
kann sehr individuell sein aber es waren
alle sofort dafür und und zwar sehr
wichtig dass wir nach insgesamt 34 tagen
im einsatzgebiet zurückgekehrt sind mit
fast unserem ganzen material leider
haben wir teil verloren auch im einsatz
dass die helfer sehr zeitnah darüber
sprechen können wir diese eindrücke
festigen sich man hat so eine phase wo
man das von sich wegschieben kann und
dann bricht über einen hinein am
nächsten tag oder so und dann gibt es
auf der einen seite die residenz die ein
so ein bisschen geschützt
man spricht darüber man verinnerlicht
dass ein bisschen und dann irgendwann
ist man aber einem punkt wo man
vielleicht feststellt es reicht nicht
mit irgendwie manfred zu sprechen ich
brauche ein bisschen professionelle
hilfe
dafür machen wir diese gespräche und
über die kann dann auch noch
professionellere hilfe vermittelt werden
es sind bilder wie diese die wir jetzt
hier auf das notebook umschalten sehen
können die zum beispiel über facebook
gepostet werden das ist ein ordner 2
schoss der offenbar bis vor kurzem noch
von der außenwelt abgeschnitten war und
hier sehen wir das was sie gerade
beschrieben haben häuser die aussehen
wie wie im kriegsgebiet da ist kein
stein mehr auf dem anderen
und wenn man hier in die kommentare geht
dann sieht man aber auch dass es
leute gibt die unterstützen wollen die
sagen ganz praktisch ich hab das und das
gerät ich habe hundefutter weil ich eine
tierhandlung habe ich möchte da
hinfahren und dann sieht man auch dass
in den sozialen medien gesagt wird ok
vater an und dann da und da oder vater
und da weil da kontrolliert die polizei
nicht und da würde ich sie jetzt fragen
was ist da das richtige vorgehen hilfe
anbieten ja aber nicht auf eigene faust
irgendwo hinfahren
es gibt keinen absoluten master weg im
moment also grundsätzlich macht ist in
hilfe immer in irgendeiner form zu
professionalisieren auch die betroffenen
da man hat ja sofort gesagt das muss
irgendwie organisiert werden und einfach
blind irgendwohin fahren ist meistens
nicht die richtige lösen natürlich kann
es trotzdem sein dass man irgendwo
ankommt und irgendwo auch helfen kann es
kann aber auch sehr schnell passieren
sie müssen sich vorstände liegen ja
häuser trümmer die sind ja nicht fest
die können sich bewegen
man kann also sehr schön als helfer dann
auch selber betroffen werden
deswegen ist es wichtig auch eine
gewisse sicherheit zu schaffen wo kann
ich gut arbeiten von weifang nicht an
vieles muss beurteilt werden
am anfang sind feuerwehrtrupps da habe
ich selber bilder vom gesehen von
kollegen die im einsatz waren zu zweit
in ortschaften geschickt wurde um eine
erkunden so genannte erkundung zu machen
erstmal zusehen wo ist wie viel hilfe
notwendig weil auch das ist ja wichtig
immer noch eine priorisierung
vorzunehmen wobei ich hin
wenn ich dann irgendwann weiß da sind
ganz viele die helfen dann muss ich da
vielleicht moment gar nicht hin sondern
fahre wohin wohl niemand ist das ist ein
problem mit den sozialen medien
heutzutage einsatzkräfte neigen dazu
sich nicht zu filmen wenn sie im einsatz
sind und den ganzen tag bei facebook
rumzuhängen die meisten die ich kenne
schalten die sozialen medien komplett
aus um sich dem auch nicht hin zu geben
weil auch da es werden einzelne
eindrücke gezeigt ein bild vom
nürburgring wo 200 autos stehen und
sofort bricht die kommentarlos die steht
sich da die füße platt dass es aber oft
kräfte sind die schon tage lang im
einsatz sind und da vielleicht mal einen
tag pause machen oder dass auch die
autos da stehen beim nur die kräfte
ausgetauscht werden das gibt es auch
dass kräfte zentralisiert werden müssen
um zu bestimmten punkten hin geführt zu
werden das weiß der leider nicht das
kann ich auch verstehen aber ich würde
mir wünschen dass viele sich erst
informieren bevor sie auf den
einsatzkräften und auch den freiwilligen
helfern rumhacken
wie sich einen eindruck verschaffen
sagen weil sie den nürburgring
angesprochen haben der ist ja quasi zum
drehkreuz geworden und auch ganz viele
sachspenden sind dort gelandet mein
kollege ron böse hat dort gedreht und
wirklich unglaubliche bilder mitgebracht
im schatten der nürburg liegt
deutschlands bekannteste rennstrecke der
nürburgring und er ist hier der
pressesprecher alexander gerhardt 41
jahre alt seine themen motorsport und
firmenevents jetzt managt er die
sachspenden für die flutopfer in den
ersten raum unseres sammelt zentrums
wird am donnerstagabend alles begonnen
es war die annahmestelle das heißt die
menschen sind hier vorne angefahren
haben ihre sachspenden abgegeben
dadurch dass sich diese nachricht aber
so verbreitet hat wird das so viel dass
wir dann nach diesem raum die nächsten
hallen auch noch nehmen mussten eben als
ausweichraum auf rund 10.000
quadratmetern lagern kleiderspenden
spielzeug und nahrungsmittel eine nur
schwer zu bewältigen die flut
materieller anteilnahme die vielen
sachspenden müssen sortiert werden eine
logistische meisterleistung
und das haben wir alles wenn man das
jetzt hier sieht und das ist der dritte
ausreichen dann kann man sich vorstellen
was hier alles angekommen ist auf der
einen seite eine riesige
hilfsbereitschaft und auf der anderen
seite macht das klar worum wir
irgendwann sagen mussten wir können es
leider nicht mehr annehmen gh dreht geld
statt sachspenden würde jetzt besser
helfen wenn jemand etwas gutes tun
möchte dann ist es wirklich mit einer
mit einer spende auf eines der
spendenkonten
so schrecklich die flutkatastrophe auch
ist die spenden zeigen die opfer sind
nicht allein die solidarität ist groß
tja also wirklich wirklich wahnsinnig
viele sachspenden auch unglaublich viele
geldspenden
es wurde gerade angesprochen spenden sie
lieber geld als sandmann wird der sache
gar nicht mehr her aber auch bei er ist
die hilfsbereitschaft einfach
unglaublich groß und auch hier in der
community ist unglaublich viel
wertschätzung für die helferinnen und
helfer stephan weil er schreibt über
facebook jetzt kommt von überall hilfe
helfer hilfsgüter nahrungsmittel geld
wie immer könnte es mehr sein und
möglicherweise ließe sich das eine oder
andere besser koordinieren
trotzdem sehe ich seit dem ersten moment
dieser großen katastrophe eine riesige
hilfswelle professionell wie von
bürgerinnen und bürgern deutschland
rückt zusammen deutschland hilft sich
wie sonst selten ist das auch ihr
eindruck absolut also ich hatte vorher
ich bin ja auch ein komme aus der
generation die durch social media
mitgeprägt wird wo man oft denkt wow so
viele negative kommentare ein krasses
thema aber vor ort habe ich das nicht
erlebt ich habe vor ort nur eine
absolute hilfsbereitschaft erlebt
pragmatische schnelle hilfe nette leute
ich stand abends an der weil ich einfach
diese diese eindrücke verarbeiten musste
bevor wir weiter gefahren sind wie haben
uns mit zwei polizisten unterhalten die
an einer straßensperre standen die
feuerwehr ist vorbei gefahren und hat
essen verteilt dass sie gekocht hatten
spontan helfer sind vorbeigekommen die
da am shoppen wahrhaben was getrunken
hat sich kurz unterhalten sich
gegenseitig mal gedankt für die hilfe
auch ist ins gespräch gekommen und dann
hat man weiter gemacht jeder in seiner
aufgabe
sie haben gerade als wir die bilder als
wir die bilder auf facebook zeigt dann
haben sie ganz schön geschluckt
und wenn man hört dass es immer wieder
auch kritik an den helfern
das ist auch für sie ein emotionales
thema wie wichtig ist der support in der
bevölkerung wie wichtig ist die
wertschätzung für die hilfe die vor ort
geleistet wird super wichtig also
wertschätzung ist das allergrößte bei
wertschätzung ist die bezahlung fürs
ehrenamt unsere kräfte sind alle
ehrenamtlich also ich weiß nicht wie man
es in prozent ausdrücken kann ob er 90
prozent ehrenamtlich
sie sagten ja von berufsfeuerwehren das
verhältnis von berufsfeuerwehr
freiwillige feuerwehr das glaube ich
auch zehn zu eins in deutschland oder so
ich weiß es nicht genau aber auch bei
uns unsere kräfte sind fast alle
ehrenamtlich das heißt die verzichten
gerade aus arbeiten da gibt es natürlich
lohnersatz strukturen dahinter aber die
bringen sich freiwillig ein
und wir brauchen auch mehr davon also
alle organisationen haben bedarf an
hilfe vom thw der feuerwehr wir dlrg
malteser dlrg jetzt ha also alle alle
brauchen hilfe die gesamte blaulicht
familie wir selber gerne nennen
und wir sind immer nur so stark wie wir
beamten sind desto weniger sich
engagieren und lieber daheim an facebook
post absetzen die sind halt nicht da ist
ja auch eine langfristige sache wenn
sich jetzt leute entschließen in die
feuerwehr einzutreten und sich dort zu
engagieren langfristig dann ist
natürlich dem land auch noch mal mehr
geholfen
die müssen doch erstmal ausgebildet
werden also wenn ich jetzt heute bei uns
zum beispiel eintreten würde
traurig bestimmten jahr bis ich so weit
bin dass ich als einfacher sanitäter
gehen kann ich muss ganz viele
grundlagen lernen ein grundverständnis
entwickeln wissen was kann ich was kann
ich nicht wann brauche ich welche hilfe
damit nämlich genau diese melde ketten
funktionieren auch im kleinen sonst sind
wir sanitätsdienst zu machen bei
veranstaltungen muss ich ja wissen wo
ist der moment dass ich mehr hilfe hier
brauchen wo er kenne ich hier braucht
sehr viel mehr hilfe wenn ein feuer
ausbricht oder ähnliches jackie doch
schreibt auch über youtube ich möchte
noch einmal allen rettungskräften meinen
dank und vollsten respekt aussprechen
man darf nicht vergessen viele sind
ehrenamtlich dort und riskieren ihr
leben also wie gesagt das ist hier die
einhellige meinung großer respekt ich
finde es immer sehr schade wenn
differenziert wird zwischen
ehrenamtlichen und spontane von bald
alle einen tollen job machen das wollte
ich nämlich auch gerade noch sagen
nikosia schreibt über facebook es geht
vorwärts dank der ganzen landwirte und
freiwilligen helfer leben alles aus
eigener tasche bezahlen
man sieht ich zitiere dass wir im
notfall keine regierung benötigen denn
die machen sowieso nur wahlkampf auf dem
rücken der ganzen opfer das ist quasi
versichert nehmen sie es mir nicht übel
aber das ist quasi das gegenüberstellen
von privater und staatlicher hilfe hund
oder eine konkurrenz und das kleiner
oder größer machen das einen oder
anderen hat er sicher dann punkt oder
muss man sagen wir brauchen beides wir
brauchen definitiv beides ist muss wenn
die menschen nicht mehr hilfsbereit
untereinander sind wie soll eine
gesellschaft dann funktionieren wenn
auch das ist ja nichts anderes was ich
beim roten kreuz nach ich gehe zum roten
kreuz weil ich anderen menschen helfen
möchte weil ich das intrinsische gefühl
habe ich muss helfen
deswegen bin ich bei dem verein und
nicht nicht weil ich da spaß haben weil
ich glaube am blauen blicken der autos
fahren will sondern weil ich menschen
helfen will das andere kommt mit dazu
und jeder der bock drauf hat der ist
herzlich willkommen wir brauchen leute
aber genauso ist es natürlich super wenn
man sagt ich kann jetzt spontan da
helfen der staat kann nicht alles
organisieren für die menschen
jeder hat auch eine selbstverantwortung
für sich und für andere
natürlich gibt es da viel was man
kritisieren kann im nachhinein das wird
garantiert alles sehr genau
aufgearbeitet werden das finde ich auch
gut und richtig
auch dass die strukturen sich anpassen
und verändern man kann aus allem was
passiert und was man tut nur lernen am
ende also auch auf stapelt man braucht
den staat wenn ich sie richtig verstehe
aber auch da muss man jetzt eben genau
gucken wo muss man nach houston las man
sie reden wieder aufbaue wer hat welche
wahn systeme haben versagt wie kann man
katastrophenschutz fit für die zukunft
machen das muss alles passieren aber nur
mit landwirten geht es am ende auch
nicht aber auch mit landwirten geht sehr
gut also es ist er über videos von
einzelnen die sich den film aber auch da
da sind was ich nicht 1000 landwirte
davon film sich drei und der rest
arbeitet einfach vor sich hin und der
die sind nett und freundlich zueinander
deshalb vor ort die leute sind
hilfsbereit absolut wir sehen auch dass
aus ganz deutschland hilfe kommt aus
schleswig holstein sind heute 600
helferinnen und helfern nach rheinland
pfalz aus aufgebrochen
das sehen wir hier sie kommen unter
anderem von der feuerwehr von den
johannitern und vom drk die meisten von
ihnen ehrenamtlich
insgesamt sind rund 200 fahrzeuge
unterwegs aus nordfriesland morgen früh
ab 7 uhr sollen sie dann die
einsatzkräfte vor ort unterstützen
der einsatz soll drei tage dauern und
bei bedarf können die helferinnen und
helfer aber auch bis zu fünf tage dort
bleiben
herr braun schädel wie läuft das ab also
nordfriesland ist nicht um die ecke und
muss schlafen die wie werden die
versorgt was machen die frau
es gibt es gibt ja einheiten aller art
es gibt verpflegungs einheiten
betreuungs anhalten sanitätseinheiten
die feuerwehr hat spezialisierte
einheiten das thw hat einheiten die
können räumen
die können brücken bauen und diese
einheiten müssen uns zueinander geführt
werden wenn man dann weiß ich habe jetzt
hier sehr viele sanitäter dann muss ich
mir auch eine struktur überlegen wie
werden die verpflegt wo können die
schlafen und da kommen wir wieder zurück
zum nürburgring
das ist natürlich der nürburgring ist
für die menschen eine rennstrecke
deshalb passt es im ersten und
wahrscheinlich in den köpfen nicht
zusammen so und es der nur wohin aber
eine große fläche wo viele autos geparkt
werden können wo es hallen gibt und das
ist optimal dem moment man kann die
leute da leichthin führen da gibt es
große verkehrswege weil er sonst viele
zuschauer hin fahren da kann man viele
autos parken die können da übernachten
die helfer können dahingehend von deinen
einsatz geführt werden
genauso kann es aber sein dass die hilfe
an orten sind wo sie selber weihnachten
müssen meine helfer zum beispiel weil
das die lage so ergeben hat haben da
geschlafen oder wir haben den
schichtbetrieb durch mainz ausgetauscht
hat also einen shuttleverkehr rauf und
runter gefahren
es wurde eben sehr schön gesagt die
sollen drei bis fünf tagen den einsatz
sein
das soll so sein ob das so funktioniert
stellt sich erst vor ort rausstellen man
kann nicht alles vorab klären und
zweifelsfall wird die hilfe geschickt
und dann muss man nachjustieren
wir nennen das alle und alle
einsatzkräfte kennen diesen satz leben
in der lage vor ort muss entschieden
werden und dann muss nachjustiert werden
was wir benötigt wird
das führt uns wieder zur kinderbetreuung
ja und damit können wir wenn wir die
sendung damit angefangen haben auch
gerne die sendung beenden denn das ist
ja auch ein blick in die zukunft denn
das ist ja das hört sich vielleicht nach
einem banalen problem an aber das ist ja
in so einer katastrophe existenziell
und wenn wir überlegen wie bauen wir den
katastrophenschutz und die
eigenverantwortung und das netz in
diesem land so auf dass wir in zukunft
besser gerüstet sind
was für möglichkeiten und chancen
sollten wir da jetzt nutzen um besser
gerüstet zu sein
ich denke es braucht die menschen und
den staat am ende das heißt die kommune
das land oder der bund sei es der
spontane helfer vor ort jeder sollte
sich überlegen bin ich nicht geeignet in
die feuerwehr ins thw zum drk zu anderen
organisationen zu gehen kann ich mich
dann nicht doch engagieren habe ich ein
paar minuten zeit aber genau so müssen
sich die staatlichen strukturen
überlegen funktioniert der
katastrophenschutz sowie jetzt
aufgestellt ist gut und ausreichend
oder müssen wir es anders machen müssen
wir mehr zentralisieren oder mehr
dezentralisieren
beides bietet vor und nachteile sagt jan
braun schädel vom deutschen roten kreuz
vielen dank dass sie bei uns im studio
waren und ich entlasse sie nicht ohne
einen kommentar und einen ein sehr sehr
positives feedback von tina alpin ski
über facebook ein sehr sympathischer
ruhiger mann alles was er erklärt und
analysiert hört sich so richtig an
danke herr braun so schön danke von der
community an sie und danke auch von mir
und uns dass sie heute abend hier im
studio waren und alles gute für sie und
ihre kollegen im einsatz danke schön und
sie liebe userinnen und user können zu
hause auch helfen wenn sie möchten und
spenden hier ist unser spendenaufruf vom
aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe die
bahn de 6 5 104 106 100 104 106 100
stichwort zdf hochwasser deutschland und
verweisen möchte ich außerdem an dieser
stelle auf den großen themen abend hier
im zdf ist beginnt mit der großen
reportage von zdf zeit um viertel nach
acht trauert zerstörung hilfe die tage
nach der flut dann geht es weiter mit
frontal21 und der frage was ist
schiefgelaufen beim warnsystem und wo
muss man beim katastrophenschutz noch
nachbessern und weit bis nach
mitternacht wird markus lanz mit einer
gesprächsrunde noch einmal analysieren
was passiert ist und was getan werden
muss also bleiben sie informiert bleiben
sie hier bei uns im zdf und ich sage
tschüss und einen guten abend